The next, uh, today's voicemail at two, one
nine two, David P, which I'm going to play
for you.
This may be the next character in David Pakman
show callers.
I'm calling this person hillbilly Trumpist
and I say it with total peace and love.
I don't mean it as an offensive term.
I, I'm just [inaudible].
I played this voicemail last week during a
live stream when it came in.
And hillbilly Trumpist was the way that a,
that was the consensus name for this individual.
Now, before I play it, if you want to call
in and leave a voicemail, you can do that
by calling two one nine two.
David P two, one nine two.
David P, this is furious hillbilly Trumpist.
I present him to you today.
Yeah.
Hey David, Pacman, you know, you think that
it's a damn bad living in the United States
and what Trump's going.
Maybe you ought to leave the sucker load,
pick up your, move your ass to Iran so you
can kiss their ashes.
What do you think of that?
Get her done, buddy.
Bye.
Yeah, let's see.
I mean, okay, so this is, this is a very furious,
angry person who maybe is not willing to see
reason.
This entire concept of if you don't like it,
leave.
It actually has a pretty ugly history.
And we've talked about that before on the
show.
We've seen Donald Trump apply it to the ethnic
minority Congress women, some of whom, uh,
he sees as clearly more loyal to other countries
than the United States, the individuals known
as the squad.
Um, and it's, it's the idea of if you don't
like it, leave has a very ugly past.
And as I've said before, and I will say again,
why would I leave if I have ideas for how
things could just get better here?
Like clearly the people who say, Hey, here's
something that's not working well in United
States.
Here's how it could work better.
Here's an ideology that's not good in the
United States.
We clearly want to live here because we do.
Right?
I mean, to some extent it is hard to find
a different place to live if you don't have
some kind of a path to citizenship elsewhere.
So, so you can say some people may be stuck
here and that's another issue.
Going to another country.
It's not as easy as some might think, but
we want to improve the country we live in.
We are invested in improving the country.
So when we talk about let's improve education,
when we say let's elect better people, when
we say let's fix money in politics so that
the political system works better, let's do
our fair share and maybe even more to deal
with what's going on with the climate and
the environment.
Uh, we do it because we are invested in improving
things.
Here it's it, it's sort of a weird quitter's
mentality to say, Oh, if you don't like something
here, go somewhere else.
And by the way, Iran is not the place I would
go.
I have no interest in living in a radical
theocracy that that's, there's been nothing
I've ever said on this program that would
suggest that's where I would go.
Interestingly, the people that would better
fit in in a religious theocracy, whether it's
Saudi Arabia or Iran or whatever, it's the
Christian version of those same people here
in the United States who are mostly on the
political right, so there's the additional
irony that actually it is they who might better
fit in.
Of course they think it's the wrong theocracy.
They want it to be a Christian theocracy rather
than an Islamic one, but that that irony seems
to be sort of lost on them.
We've got a great bonus show for you today,
judge Judy is supporting a democratic candidate
and that candidate is Michael Bloomberg and
there's actually some interesting stuff going
on related to that which I want to talk about.
The Trump administration is also rolling back
an Obama era joint employer rule, which a
lot of people don't even know about.
And it's important.
And we're going to dig into that on today's
bonus show.
And also retired Pope Benedict is what Benedict
Joseph Ratzinger was his pre Pope name, I
believe, retired Pope Benedict, who was in
his nineties now is warning Pope Francis against
relaxing those priestly celibacy rules, which
is actually one of the Pope Francis has done
things that uh, Popa Francis has done, things
that I like and things that I dislike.
And in the end, it's still the Pope of the
Catholic church.
Relaxing those priestly celibacy rules actually
would, would be a really good thing.
And a Pope Benedict is against it.
So we will talk about that and much more on
today's bonus show, two ways to get instant
access.
Number one, become a member@joinpacman.com
number two, become a patron@patrion.com slash
[inaudible]
David Pakman show.
Either way, I will see you on the bonus show
in mere minutes from now in mere minutes,
not minutes.
The David Pakman show@davidpakman.com [inaudible].